hi the three greatest threats to the
recovery of the economies around the
world and hollering the first one is
trade protectionism and its impact
around the world whether the fit for the
production of them for countries around
the world is going to lead to more and
more trade wars that's number one the
second one is are the key economies
around the world doing enough pause the
financial crisis how we take an
effective and sufficient steps to
counterbalance the negative effects of
the of the recent financial downturn the
third point that I would raise is the
increase in commodity prices especially
oil and gas that can have an effect
effect and the last point that I want to
highlight is that while gdp growth and
emerging markets are much much higher
than developed economies capital flows
are still flowing from the East the West
so I'd say these are both key points
that hinder the recovery of economies
around the world